[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
directo américa y por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañera daniela
blandón daniela la oecd rebajó las
previsiones de crecimiento para este año
cuéntenos hola andrés muy buenas noches
pues de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos
entregó su informe más reciente de
perspectivas económicas esto en el marco
del foro sobre américa latina y el
caribe que tiene lugar en parís y que es
auspiciado también en conjunto con el
gobierno francés y el banco
interamericano de desarrollo ahora
siguiendo los pasos del banco mundial
que lo hizo un día antes la ocde también
cree que la guerra le quitará fuerza al
crecimiento mundial por eso ya no espera
que el pib global crezca este año 4.5
por ciento sino 3 por ciento y la razón
que esgrime es la misma la guerra en
ucrania por lo que pidió reforzar las
sanciones contra rusia
a comienzos de año la recuperación
estaba bien asentada la inflación estaba
subiendo pero debía hacer algo temporal
con la guerra el crecimiento económico
será más bajo en inflación más elevada
durante más tiempo gracias al robo y las
sanciones son la consecuencia directa de
la agresión ilegal de rusia o ucrania lo
que estamos viendo es que están siendo
efectivas están funcionando también
efectivos de walking
bueno y se preguntarán entonces en la
región cómo nos va pues coincide la ocde
casi totalmente con el banco mundial en
que colombia y argentina tendrán un
mejor crecimiento siendo el primero o
sea colombia la nación que más crecerá
dentro del también conocido como club de
países ricos mientras que méxico chile y
brasil van a experimentar un crecimiento
menor al que se esperaba en el anterior
reporte de este organismo daniele los
consumidores europeos también pueden
ayudar a eliminar la dependencia de los
hidrocarburos rusos cómo es esto bueno
al menos eso es lo que considera la
agencia internacional de energía que
cree que el próximo invierno habrá
escasez de gas por el embargo a rusia
sobre todo en los países más
dependientes pero yo emitió una serie de
recomendaciones de consumo para que
eliminar ese vínculo comercial con rusia
sea menos traumático por ejemplo dice
que si los hogares europeos se redujeran
en dos grados la temperatura de sus
casas durante el invierno se podría
ahorrar lo equivalente a todo el gas que
llega por el gasoducto nord stream 1
pero la preocupación se extiende también
al mercado petrolero
ahora en verano cuando aumenta la
demanda de combustibles en ese sentido
dice que si las economías avanzadas
bajarán en 110 kilómetros por hora los
límites de velocidad se podrían ahorrar
medio millón de barriles diarios de
petróleo que es la mitad de lo que ha
dejado de exportar rusia daniela y chile
ve posible una recesión económica en
ese es el vaticinio andrés del banco
central que acaba de subir su pronóstico
de crecimiento para este año pero con
una advertencia y es que también podría
rebajar el del 2023 porque cree que el
mayor dinamismo en el consumo se va a ir
desacelerando este informe coincide con
la publicación de la inflación de mayo
que fue por quinto mes consecutivo alta
y que está por encima del 10% anual una
cifra que no se veía en ese país desde
hace 30 años ese nivel hizo justamente
que el banco central subiera otra vez la
tasa de interés que en la pandemia sube
en un mínimo del 0,5 por ciento y ahora
ya va en el 9% aumento de conocer los
indicadores andrés un wall street en
cerro en rojo en medio de las
preocupaciones por lado aceleración
económica que plantearon tanto el banco
mundial como la uc de este mal
comportamiento arrastró también a las
bolsas en américa latina y también le
tengo una noticia bursátil y es que el
fondo monetario internacional abrió la
vía para desembolsar más de 40 más de 4
mil millones de dólares a argentina esto
en el marco de la negociación de su
deuda y también se vieron descensos en
las bolsas de europa allí los
inversionistas se preparan no solamente
para la reunión del banco central
europeo este jueves sino también para la
reserva federal en la próxima semana y
están muy pendientes de las tasas de
interés
esta cifra dada del día 100 mil millones
de dólares andrés éstos son los ingresos
anuales que espera alcanzar spotify en
los próximos 10 años una apuesta muy
agresiva si se tiene en cuenta que en
2021 sus ingresos fueron de poco más de
11 mil millones quiere decir que tendría
que multiplicar por 10 sus ingresos si
es que la acción ha perdido más de la
mitad de su valor de este año en wall
street por eso quieren darles como
confianza también a los inversionistas
también la muchas gracias por la
información económica aquí en directo
bueno andrés